and
and a little treat I brought that comes
with my most recent book for anybody who
wants it after the talk and basically in
the book what I talk about is I talk
about you know technology is very
powerful and when you're in possession
of a tool that's very powerful it's a
great question to ask what what to do
with this tools and that question is
actually not a technological question
it's a human question and so in order
finally in order to create great
technologies it requires a also a great
non-technological philosophy create it
requires a philosophy of life and the
stronger and more differentiated and
more compelling your philosophy of life
is the stronger more differentiated and
more compelling the technology you were
built with that as a foundation will be
so I'm going to talk about a little bit
of that interplay today with with a
couple of examples one of the examples
being some of the work that I've done in
education over the past couple years but
a lot of it is more kind of more in
detail expressed in the book but I want
to start with this wonderful calculation
made in the 1970s by a radical Catholic
priest named Ivan Illich and Ivan Illich
wanted to calculate the true speed of a
car and he said you know in order to
calculate the true speed of a car you
can't just take the distance that it
travels and divided by the time that it
takes to get there you also have to take
into account the time that you have to
work in order to afford the car and the
time that you sit in traffic in order to
get to work and so on and so forth and
he found that once you internalize all
the externalities of the car the true
speed of a car is about five kilometers
an hour it's about walking speed and
this is crazy and it's important and and
he used this as an illustrative example
of a philosophy that he called counter
productivity
where he said you know technologies tend
to bring efficiencies up until a certain
point of application but beyond that
point of application they bring they
tend to bring in efficiencies in the
exact opposite direction of the purpose
for which the technology was intended
and this is true not just for
automobiles but it's true for
antibiotics and emails and so on and so
forth we live in an era of
counterproductive technology and so I've
thought a lot about this because I I'd
like to make technologies and I would
like the technologies to do what I want
them to do and okay the conclusion that
i came to is that it's not technology
per se that leads to counter
productivity it's that we tend to build
a certain kind of technology a
technology that we call cell freedom
that I call itself reinforcement
technologies technologies who's used to
leads to more use in the car is a great
example of this the car enables
centralization of work and and suburbs
and highways which then makes the car
necessary which then clogs the highways
and you know that you're in an addictive
spiral when the remedy is more of the
same more highways and more cars but
it's possible I think to create a
different kind of technology a
technology whose use doesn't lead to
more use but a technology whose use
leads to less use a technology that
kicks off with social process that no
longer needs the technology itself and
we see glimmers of this in some of our
technologies today an online dating site
is a great example if it works you don't
need to use it anymore and so so so I
started getting interested in the
opposite of self reinforcing
technologies I started getting
interested in self-limiting technologies
and I was thinking about this a lot in
around 2011-2012 and I was living in San
Francisco at the time and I remember I
was going on a walk trying to clear my
head and thinking about this stuff and I
noticed that there was a lot of food
trucks around like more than there had
been that's like why are there so many
food trucks and why now
and so I started asking around and I
started asking the food trucks and it
turned out that it was because of
Twitter you see at the time it was very
difficult to get a food truck license in
San Francisco but with Twitter illegal
food trucks could thrive because they
park in a different spot every day and
tweet out where they were so they
wouldn't get caught but their customers
would know where they were and it gets
better because at a certain point the
legal food trucks caught wind of this
took a look at the Twitter followers of
the illegal food trucks and said hey
this is a food truck customer database
and so they started following the
followers of the illegal food trucks who
followed them back and this community
formed around food trucks and that
community work to shape a good work to
change the regulations with San
Francisco about food truck licensure and
this was fascinating to me because this
was software shaping the city it was the
Internet shaping physical space or to be
more precise it was software kicking off
a social process that in turn shape the
city um and I would I got very
interested because food trucks are like
the cheapest and easiest way to shape
the city they're like the Canaries in
the coal mine like if it's happening
with food trucks now it's likely going
to happen with lots of other things in
the future and so I started getting
interested in how to think about
software shaping the city and how to
systematize first and how to kind of use
the power that we have with with
software to help to shape more beautiful
more vibrant cities and so I started
with an experiment I I in 2012 i went to
the media lab and i started by doing a
show i was invited to do a show at this
museum called the Schism mouth museum in
sweden and and so in the show what i did
is i wrote a number of programs that
would give instructions to people in the
museum to make marks on the wall and
together the software and the people
would create large-scale artworks so in
this in this program we have the first
person to draw a circle and then we
asked
each person following that to draw a
circle tangent to an existing circle and
then when there was no more space
remaining we asked people to color in
the negative space and so this is how
that piece turned out and so we did a
number of these pieces so we also this
is one that the instructions were the
first few people drew lines the second
people in drew lines from intersection
point to other intersection points the
next people colored in space the next
people bisected space and there was a
series of there was a series of
instructions with dinner which generated
this piece and pieces like this this one
I had the first person to draw a
squiggly line and then ask each person
to draw a line exactly adjacent to an
existing line and this one I made a grid
a black-and-white grid and that's each
person to paste a polygon into the grid
such that two sides match up um and so
we did a number of these pieces and in
each of these pieces basically I
followed the same process I started by
defining a pattern in physical space
then I created a social process by which
other people could create that or
similar patterns and then I created
software to enable that social process
and I was very interested in this and
and the wall drawings were were intended
to be a metaphor I was interested in
creating art but I was even more
interested in helping people to create
the cities that they wanted to be in so
I started the second experiment where we
had just moved to cambridge and our son
was two years old at the time and my
wife said you have one job in this move
and it's to find a school for Dario an
accident that little I think I can do
and so I went and I looked at a whole
bunch of schools and I came back
and I told my life my wife I decided
what we're going to do for schools I'm
going to start a school but it wasn't
the assignment she actually at one point
she said you know sometimes being
married to you is like feels like being
the sorcerer's apprentice in Fantasia
like I have all this power to tell you
what to do but absolutely no control of
what you're actually going to do so I'm
so but but she was cool with it and I
started to school and the school was
called wildflower montessori school and
there were nine principles to the school
and I'll talk about a few of them right
now so the first principle is that it's
a shopfront school and this is not my
idea it's an idea that i got from
christopher alexander who's an architect
who wrote this beautiful book called a
pattern language and in this book one of
the patterns he describes he observed in
the 70s that you know about thirty
percent of the cost of operating a
school goes to the cost of operating a
large school and so he said I have a
simple solution make small schools 12
teachers 20 children put it in a shop
front and he said not only you decrease
the cost and increase the teacher
autonomy but you could also then put
schools all over the city such that
every child could walk to school and he
showed this research showing the
benefits to learning from walking to
school so that the first principle is
that is a shopfront school the second
principle is it's a Montessori School
and the way that my two sentence
description of Montessori is that is the
philosophy of childhood that's these
children not as blank slates to be
filled up with knowledge but as little
people in the process of constructing
themselves and and they have the ability
to construct themselves and so the
teachers role is to prepare the
environment and to remove the obstacles
for that important process of self
construction
that's the second principle at the
montessori school the third principle is
that it's a lab school and lots of
stories lends itself very well to being
a lat school because Montessori is
predicated on observation so this is
Maria Montessori back in the day and you
see her sitting back and observing the
children doing their work and and when
she found that there was an obstacle
than she would adjust the environment or
or connect a child to the environment
but observation was the primary
principle by which Montessori last and
you see this today you see you see my
story teachers today often will step
back sit in the corner and observe and
jot down their notes and this is a very
lovely tradition in Montessori I think
one of the challenges is that what you
end up with is you end up with lots of
notes and it's difficult to do things
like go back and synthesize those notes
to have an understanding of the child or
to collect lots of these different notes
among lots of different teachers to
understand children in general and so so
what we did is we we created these
sensors in the lab and the sensors we
put in the child's shoe and so once the
sensors in the shoe just looks like a
shoe but it happens to have a sensor
embedded inside and so we not only put
it in the shoe but we also put it in the
trays for the materials and each month
astoria material teaches a specific
thing so you start to get an
understanding of the interaction between
a child and the material and then we
also put it in different regions of the
classroom and because in a Montessori
environment each area of the classroom
corresponds to a curriculum area you
have a map area you have a language area
you have a practical life area and so
then what happens is it then the
children go about and spend their day
and this is a lot of flowers this is the
first school to spend their day in the
classroom
and what's actually happening on the
sensors front is the Bluetooth sensors
are interacting with one another and so
we're gaining information of that who
each child interacts with what materials
they interact with and what areas
they're in and then and then at the end
of the day the teacher uploads the data
from the shoes and it's always fun for
me to see teachers uploading data from
shoes I feel very futuristic and then
they can review the data but they also
have David can review the data in line
but they also have lots of data that
they can review offline and so then we
feed this data into data visualization
so for example we have a sense of how
much time each child spends with each
material each week and this is very
powerful because in Montessori each
material teaches a very specific thing
so when you know what materials each
child is spending time with you have a
sense of what they're spending time
learning and then we also the other
thing about Martha stories each material
falls into a curriculum area so we can
say over the course of the week how much
time they spent in each curriculum area
as compared to the rest of the classroom
and the rest of all of the classrooms
that are also good with these sensors
and we can do that not only over the
course of the week but we can do it over
the course of the year so you see for
example this child is not interested in
math until the end of the year where
they get very interested in that and
then we can do fun things like impute
the social network of the classroom by
seeing who interacts with whom and
that's very important because Montessori
is very peer learning based you the
mixed age classrooms age three to six
and a lot of times like a child will
come after a teacher for a presentation
and she says that's so that sounds like
something that a friend can help you
with and and so they tend to naturally
go peer-to-peer and so we can understand
not just the social network of the
classroom how learning get diffused over
that social network
and then we can do things like once we
have that we can we can use tools that
we know how to use so for example hidden
Markov models to understand hidden
states in the child and how they get
observed in in the materials that
they're working on our behaviors that
they're exhibiting and we can also do
things like on the social network of the
classroom dupage like page rank like
algorithms to understand the influence
of each child so that's the third
principle at the event is a lab school
longer in the third principle the fourth
principle is I feel like children have
so much to learn from seeing adults in
their work and adults have so much to
learn from children being around but
right now as a society we tend to
separate out adults and children and
then bring them together for a short
period of time at the end of the day so
here what we do is the school has an
artist in residence who has a studio in
the school so that children have access
to to an adult doing the work of her
life and this is kim who is the artist
in residence at wildflower the first
year taking a break from her studio and
coming out into the classroom and doing
some work with Dario my son the fifth
principle is I trained for nine years
after high school to become a professor
but my training to become a father
consisted of reading like three books
like there was a mismatch between the
importance of the job and the training
that I had for it and so I wanted the
space not just for children to learn but
for parents to learn and I wanted to
blur the boundaries between
homeschooling and institutional
schooling and create a truly miss page
learning environment and so each parent
spends a few hours a month in the
classroom alongside their child learning
about learning about Marcus Ori and also
just learning about how the child spends
their days with spending that time with
their child the sixth
bull is that if you have a big school
you think about having kind of a
playground in a cafeteria and so on but
it's a small school you can't have over
the single classroom tool you don't
really have those things so instead we
work to build the city to be friendlier
to children and families so for example
we took the parking spot the two parking
spots in front of wild flower and made
it into a park and the coffee shop next
door we asked them to put a low table in
the coffee shop so that the children
could go have lunch at the coffee shop
next door and with both of these things
they were both space for the children of
the school but they ended up being
spaces for children in the city in
general and so you know I all of these
principles led to like a school
experience that was really lovely for my
child in my family but I felt like if I
did one then it would be nice for these
these 20 families and the twentyfamilies
that would continue to go through it but
I felt like if I if I created many more
of these if I created thousands of views
well it would be really a big service to
the world and so the question is how do
we go from one school to thousands of
school well what we've done so far as we
created a pattern in physical space so
so the next thing we did was we created
a social process by which other people
could create similar schools we open
source the school so to speak the
process for creating this cool yes maybe
record hundreds of what's going on and
that the key difference from other
Montessori schools or other because I
assume another monster is cool car all
of them like this
other key characteristic that is
important in the replication of two
thousand and then the part that I'm
wondering about also since you have that
data like how is it used so that you
know you want to know replicate it yeah
so to answer your first question there's
a number of things that are pretty
unique I there are there are a large
number of other Montessori schools
there's a very few shopfront montessori
school so so the shop front aspect is
unique the parent involvement montessori
is is a very precise method of education
so I remember I was talking to you I got
into this long discussion with two
teachers who were having a debate about
the table washing at the table
Washington material the table washing
exercise and the debate was do does it
should the child do it clockwise or
counterclockwise discussing clockwise or
counterclockwise and actually it's
really important because table scrubbing
is actually a pre writing exercise in
Montessori and so it's actually useful
to do it in the way that they would most
likely write cursive and and so there
was a legitimate debate but a lot of
times when you have a method that that's
precise and you have a pair come in like
a bull in a china shop and so a good job
do this do that and so on so by and
large the parent involvement is almost
not at all they're in my tutorial yeah
that's right that's right so there are
very few much story co-ops and so kind
of doing that right is a challenging
thing it requires a lot of parent
education so that's another thing a
third is that very few schools see as
their mission to shape the neighborhood
around them so each of these principles
has its its distinct its uniqueness and
so that it was more than just a
Montessori it was also kind of just
systematizing how to start any school is
tremendously valuable because when I
started wildflower I was shooting blind
you know and now I have these like this
is how you get licensed this is how what
to look for in the space this is a
number of square foot per child this is
the cost the revenue you could expect to
come in for public for private and so on
and that makes it that makes it a lot
easier to start be seen in terms of the
data so I'll speak to this more a little
bit later in the talk but the short
answer is to go from one to a few we
didn't actually need a whole lot of hard
data to suggest that this was a good
idea i mean i loved it the other
families loved it there was a wait list
there were like a hundred people who
were applying to the school for like to
open slots and so it made sense to
replicate it it the qualitative metrics
were there and we're now in the process
of kind of understand and also there's
just lots of more scientific study on
montes montessori in and of itself which
suggests that Montessori should be much
more widely spread and then what we're
doing is we're in the process of like as
we get to scale we can take this data
and have more quantitative large-scale
studies about different different
aspects things like like one of the
things that like so so a couple of like
a number of studies have shown that
month of story there's two things that
come out of Montessori one is both and
increase like it comes out higher on
cognitive measures but it also the
children come out higher around
socio-emotional measures and I believe
that a lot of it is because of the same
thing is because Montessori provides a
meditative environment by which children
can get into a flow and maintain that
flow for a long period of time and so
we're in the process of doing Studies on
for example doing GSR studies on the
children galvanic skin response studies
on the children to see what does there
and heart rate variability studies to
see do they actually get into flow how
long do they maintain flow what happened
the environment too
to promote that so on so there's all of
these studies but it needs more we now
have about at the number of schools that
we have were just starting to be able to
kind of have these studies with with an
end that's high enough for us to feel
comfortable teachers can use the data
interchange how they teach you when
there are showers all farrah yeah yeah
absolutely so there I think one of the
biggest things that we see teacher is
using is things like how much time
they're spending with each child and
started to say oh I think I could spend
a little bit more time with this child
today or things like unlike the grass
that I showed you with someone not
getting into not interested in math
until later in the year montessori is
child-directed so it's up to the child
to do it but it's up to the teacher to
link the child to the environment so a
lot of times they can say oh you know
let me link the child more to mass at
this point so those are two ways that we
see very much teachers using the data so
um so so yeah so we created we created a
social process by which other children
other people can start wildflower school
and then we created software to enable
that social process so we started
creating things like interactive maps
that show the density of children in the
city and then optimization algorithms
that show given where the existing
schools are and where the children are
in the city where optimal places to put
new schools and then we're feeding that
into user facing software to understand
what are the shop fronts available in
the areas where where schools are most
needed and then we're creating things
like okay well given the number of
students in your budget what are the
materials that you should buy in order
to start the school and then things like
a social network to allow teachers who
are interested in starting schools
connect with parents who are interested
in starting school so what we did here
is actually very similar to what we did
in the wall drawings we started by
creating a physical pattern a physical a
pattern physical space
then we created a social process by
which other people could replicate that
pattern or make similar patterns and
then we create a software to enable that
social process and the result was that
in in the two and a half years since we
started the first school 15 more
wildflower schools have started and
we're finding that each school tends to
spawn two more wildflower schools and
this was remarkable I expected and that
this would grow but I didn't expect that
it would grow as fast and I it reminded
me of a story a conversation that I had
with a friend of mine who's an
acupuncturist and I was talking to her I
said so how does it work how do you heal
people and he says cept I don't heal
people the body's energies have the
ability to heal itself but sometimes
those energies are blocked and my role
is to unblock those energies and I
thought that that was beautiful and it
was profound and I think it's true at a
level of scale above as well I think
people have the ability to heal their
own societies but sometimes the energy
is blocked and we can play a role of
unblocking those energies by making
things easier and it's obvious I think
that if you make something easier to do
more people will do it but what's less
obvious is how sensitive that
relationship is like if you make
something just a little bit easier to do
lots more people do it it's like I
remember when I was at Google we would
make a button just a little bit more
visible and millions where people would
click on it and so we could write
software to serve as an acupuncture for
society by making certain things easier
to do and then therefore unlocking the
intrinsic potential of people to heal
the world around them and I think that
is axis that is obvious that the
software that i showed the technologies
that I showed I self-limiting
technologies they they work to to create
a school that no longer needs those
technologies as a kick they kick off a
social process but no longer is so
dependent on the
oh jeez but what's less obvious is the
school's themselves are also
self-limiting technology if you if you
take a look closely at what we've been
doing we've created a school in which
which is led by the child rather than
the teacher in radically mixed-age
environments where children of multiple
ages and adults are working side by side
as opposed to kind of age separated
environment in public spaces that are
prepared for learning rather than having
the place of learning be separate from
place of the rest of the of life with a
social network that mixes teachers and
learners eventually teachers and
learners of all kinds so what we've been
doing is we've been creating a kind of
school that in the success case will
need less of itself because the whole
city becomes a place of learning and I
think that would be a beautiful result
thank you this is a franchising process
right like you have these processes and
instructions but obviously like that
what a school is going to be like a
question on people consider in there
it's the money like um you 15 different
branches that way to the user study
differently like what is it are they
like metrics like that's good or better
than your son even incorporating their
teams of three yeah yeah it's a
wonderful question and so certainly the
intent is for each school to be
different to to share the same
philosophy and values but not to be like
McDonald not to be carbon copies of one
another but rather to take the
personality of the teachers and the
children and the parents who comprise
the school and so we aim for schools to
be different and it's not that we even
have to aim for it they naturally become
different so for example one is like one
of the schools in Cambridge or the
bilingual school Spanish English
another is very nature based I mean they
spent a lot of their time in nature
because it started out with the teachers
and then it attractive families who are
into it you know so there are schools
that that end up being more heavily
special needs because that's a more
interest that's more of an interest of
the teachers who started that school and
so on so so so variability is a good
thing in the ecosystem and we want to
preserve that I think there's a second
question which is um well how do you
know I mean if so much of the quality of
a school depends on the people how do
you know whether school will be good
enough quality in order to look in order
to maintain the brand so to speak and
that to me is a branding question so the
way that we think about it is we say
everything will make open source so that
anybody can use the tools to build a
school if they'd like but in order to be
called a wildflower school in order to
have the brand you need to go through a
certification process and we're in the
process of putting together that
certification problem yes how is amazing
I'm really curious about the
artist-in-residence cribben I know you
mentioned that adults can learn a lot
and kids and just can learn a lot from
adults with their choice made to sailing
OHL micardis residence as opposed to
some other kind of succession president
and are the artists creating works that
interact with the kids really smart they
doing on a safe day we suppress so the
answer your question the artist in
residence is is a term but I mean there
are other people and residents the
important thing for me is that they work
with their hands because that allows
children to observe what they're doing
especially in the younger year in the
older years I think it's fine to have a
computer programmer in residence so so
that's kind of how we made that that's
how we kind of made that decision and
gave guidance to the school in terms of
how they work yes I mean absolutely so
Kim for example what did a gallery show
in which
it was both her work and the work of the
children in the school which was a
lovely beautiful show but also what it
turns out is that a lot of the artists
end up end up getting inspired and
interested by the children you know so
Kim for example is has been doing a lot
of much like thinking about making a lot
of Montessori materials based on based
on her time there and a Rimmel who is
one of the artists the other school
started to get interested in and he's a
filmmaker doing movies that are directed
by children so you just whatever they
say you actually do and so there's like
there's there's been a lot of cross play
between the two it's been beneficial for
both yes Michael hear your thoughts on
the line between software and people
when designing social computing system
my observation and said that people
trained in 18 computing in computer
science seek to sort of scale and
automate like you know it's all is a
similar pattern where we identify
patterns and how the world works we sort
of identify a script so to speak or
workflow that that cats can calculate
that and then they say okay now everyone
you do this yeah and in practice you
know or I'm sorry in theory i think the
belief is that and now it's scaled if
people it works but in practice i think
a lot of social phenomena are really are
swimming them that you can't be so hands
off about them and so i'm wondering it
as you think about this for video to
give an example like you know any NGO
right tries to go and make a difference
in some some environments and right but
when they're funding runs out like and
the people will have to leave if
actually people were on the ground who
are actually key to making it happen so
i'm wondering as a social computing
designer where do you sort of to put
your faith in the process and where are
you putting it into people and is there
some like
that's halfway in between home stuff
that sort of mediate and keeping keeping
things tied together yeah I know I think
I I think part of the answer to that is
that is important in designing these
systems to not think of ourselves as or
for me to not think of myself as a
social computing designer because if I
think I do that I will overweight the
amount of computing that is done and
necessary instead I think about myself
as a gardener and I'm trying to like
plant and shape and initially read and
then step back from ecosystems that
themselves have tremendous intrinsic
richness and intrinsic potential and so
my job is more like a Kickstarter of
those like we call myself often in the
context a wildfire like the second
person in a two-person bobsled like i'll
push allowed at the beginning and then
Stefan and enjoy the ride and and and so
I think kind of um my high-level answer
is the like when I mean even the word
designing and systems are fraught and
they're almost in depth there almost to
industrial for when we're trying to kind
of like see the ecosystems and so I
think once you do the framing of seating
ecosystems then the kinds of tools that
you build our tools like shovels or
things that make it a little bit easier
for for the ecosystem to continue to
grow and generate itself when you're
saying you fiddle to social environments
essentially destroyed yourself you give
a little world and then once you have
that and start saying globally actually
there are ways that technology
but you know a virus absolutely i mean a
lot of doggerel in there now is like so
so the first tent will be built with
very little software at all and then we
realize you know the teachers are really
spending a lot of their time and stress
on like doing the finances in QuickBooks
and understanding the finances and is
there a way we can build a tool to make
that easier given that the scope is
limited you know or like the teachers
are spending in power a day doing a load
no I'm sorry an hour to two a week just
like recording attendance for the week
up and so there is a natural place for
software so the software is like light
touch it's not systemic it's like tools
in the it's like garden is gardening
work it's like tools in the ecosystem
basically all right yeah are you measure
the interaction in the hugest you
measure distance if you do not
automatically so right now these sensors
is just a distance it's basically kind
of the we have a low energy bluetooth
left Kings once every few seconds and so
if that's not clear that that's
interaction and we did a couple things
we ground truth this by taking a look
and saying okay when two children are
close together within a couple feet from
another how often are they interacting
versus not interesting it turns out that
the signal is strong enough but we're
going to a are going to where there's a
lot of work to do there i mean with
computer vision with with voice
recognition and so on so this is really
a first first step yes tues data to the
teachers still on insulting written
notes for they mostly copy that no it is
really important it's really important
that we don't observe ation is so
central to montessori that we don't want
to say oh you don't have to do this
thing anymore it's kind of like saying
well you know i'm going to build you
these and artificial legs that allow you
to not have to walk anymore but then
your legs will your actual legs will
atrophy and they would be a shame for
that and so we review the same way here
and we do very close observation of the
teachers and the interaction between the
teachers and the tools to make sure that
that doesn't happen yeah how does it
play a role in the world of capitalism
you know i would argue that there are
like a search engine is a self-limiting
technology as well like if you find what
you need you don't need to use it again
for that purpose i would argue that
there are like they fit they can fit
very well with capitalism but with one
caveat i mean one of the reasons why
search is such a good business is that
it actually over took a lot of other
advertising businesses you know so it
was able to be self-limiting without and
not self-reinforcing because it has such
wide scale so it didn't need to compete
with say a newspaper for the amount of
time somebody is spending on it because
they had a two billion person reach so i
think what you'll see is you'll see kind
of you'll see kind of like certain
things reaching there like and I'd argue
the same like a bicycle is a
self-limiting tool in another way like
you should you can only ride so much in
a bicycle before you get tired but if a
company like puts out bicycles that then
overtake most car production in the
world then that company will do very
well even though there is creative
destruction in the auto industry on that
one I think
in large part I mean one can say that
may be at the root is that a a system in
which the origination of money happens
through debt that has a that requires
growth is itself not self-limiting so so
so it's interesting to think about
self-limiting tools for money and i
think there's lots of real there's been
lots of glimmers of interesting things
happening here one example is a negative
interest negative interest and so likes
during the Great Depression there were
these in order to boost the economy what
happened during like the depression and
depressions in general is money wasn't
circulating and because money wasn't
circulating it just stagnated like it
made the depression worse and so in
order to get money circulating they
introduced these things called stamps
craft which is negative currency
negative interest money we're like every
week it would be worth a little bit less
than it was the week before and
therefore people started spending money
in that kick-started the economy and you
saw this happen in various local places
with local currencies I mean one might
imagine that negative interest might
actually happen on its own we're at
almost a zero-interest environment right
now and it's not a big reach to say that
at some point that might become negative
interest just through economic dynamics
so I suspect that we could we should
also see self-limiting capitalism and
that would be interested that's a longer
conversation to have that that would be
interesting to talk about offline yes
will shotgun cool not as applies to uh
like larger or higher anal so we have
one high school and the high school was
really interesting because you know in
the and the younger grades is like some
combination of teachers or parents who
starts school the high school with the
kids and for kids to start their own
school
this amazing amazing experience that's
probably a stronger life experience than
the school had been going to the school
um I think my so I have a whole like I
gave a whole time what I see is the
future of university and I'll give like
a like a two minute summary right now is
and I think this is also true like what
I'm saying for university is also true
for high school but basically I said the
first thing is like the internet changes
things in ways that are not necessarily
obvious at the beginning they're not the
obvious answer to how the University
chick will change things how the
internet will change things so one thing
is I think the internet will change
things by one by getting rid of degrees
and the reason why is because the degree
is a proxy for knowing something first
for learning something but right now
with the internet you don't need a proxy
you can just do the thing and put it
online and so people will stop going to
university to get a degree but instead
go to university to build a portfolio
the second thing i said in the talk was
that and the analogy that I used was the
Green Bay Packers so the Green Bay
Packers used to be meat packers during
the week and then on the weekends they
would play football what happened for
trading business the beginning and now
and what happened with television and so
television made football into a business
that could scale and as a business that
could scale it made sense to
disaggregate meat packing from football
and invest in the football and so you
have people going full time you had
people really like working hard at the
football and I think a similar thing
will happen with lectures so instead of
thousands of people lecturing to
hundreds of people will have hundreds of
people lecturing to thousands of people
in lectures will become a resource like
books or so on that people have access
to so I said there would be no lectures
and instead there will be like a
resource library of lectures that people
could use and then I said the third
thing is
that is still useful to have classes and
it's just those classes will start to
look different they'll start to look
like ateliers and reading groups and
workshops and so on and so it look like
mit has this period called I ap
independent activity period and my
feeling was that it will look like iip
year round and and those courses could
be in it was workshops and Natalia's
could be initiated by faculty they could
be initiated by students that could be
as so so and it could be like a
semester-long or they could be a
year-long or they could be a week-long
and so you have this kind of fluid
organic learning environment at the
university level that looks like MIT SI
AP and then what i say is i said using
you notice that I've been starting to
kind of lower the boundary between
student and faculty like like faculty
don't give lectures students can
initiate lectures there's no degrees and
so on and so what I said is instead of
like the student distinction you'll have
everybody at the fellow and fellows
could come for four years or they could
come for like two days a week for the
rest of their life force if they should
come first six years or one year so on
and so you have this fluid eat so
basically kind of my feeling is that for
the higher grades from high school in
college it will look a student directed
with lots of resources like I ap yes I
you puncture analogy means the blockage
that you were talking about have you as
you can use scale up you had any kind of
push start from Cambridge public schools
or Boston Public Schools no in fact we
have had interest so I mean one of my
big interest is is creating public last
our schools and so of the 15 four of
them are public and my interest is is
that that number far outweighs the
private well our school I started with
tires just because they're easier to
start so so in so by and large I mean it
actually solves a lot of problems for
public districts I mean so for example
like Cambridge
has a montessori school that has a huge
waiting list but they also they have no
they have they're not going to start
another big school they don't have so
the facility space but they can start
play front you know and so there's good
interest i mean we're starting our first
public school in the boston area next
year and so so i imagine that that I
mean my intention is to have a model of
Education that all people can use
regardless of whether it's public or
district or charter or private and
regardless of the means of the families
who are who who are enrolled at the
school wonderful work I'm wondering so I
think hear you talk a lot about the
design patterns that you've used to
implement these specific instances of
the social you know social interventions
and then also the self eliminate
technology and in wondering if you
thought or could speak to a little bit
about do we need tools in order to make
these systems which is all right now I
imagine you're you know you're making
this book spoke system that has the
social network component that has these
different components what do you think
are the right tools to enable other
people or it doesn't really need to be
this bespoke drying process and by like
IP is a sec and I remember when I came
to MIT the vision was to have the stack
all the way from the built environment
down to the programming language and the
mistake that I made it was that I
started with the programming language
but then when we started building the
applications i select all right the
programming language the application
should be built first that we know the
requirements with the programming
language and so so i shifted and started
done with the built environment and
we're working our way down so so
programming languages i think is where
like domain specific programming
languages to make it easier to build
these kinds of things is where I see I
I see the tool to duck tool thank you
[Applause]